- [Instructor] What is BD, so
when they're just saying BD,
they're saying literally
the length of segment BD.
So they're saying the length
from B, point B to point D.
And B is sitting here at
negative two, D here is at five.
So you're looking at really the distance
between negative two and five.
So you literally could just
say, well, that's gonna be five,
that's kind of our endpoint,
minus negative two,
so five minus negative two
is the same thing as
five plus two, or seven.
Another way, you could
literally just count it out.
Count out the distance, you
go one, two, to get to zero,
three, four, five, six, seven,
to get all the way to five.
Or you could say, look, I got to get,
I got to go two to the right just to get,
I got to go two to the
right just to get to zero,
and I got to go five more
to the right to get to D,
so that's going to be seven.
Let's do a couple more, what is BD again?
Well, here we're going from one to four.
The distance between
one and four is three.
And then let's do one more, what is AD?
So A is a negative five,
D is all the way at four.
So we're going from negative
five to zero, which is five,
and then we're gonna go four
more, five plus four is nine.
Or you could say, hey look,
we start at negative five,
we end up at four, four
minus negative five
is the same thing as four
plus five, which is nine.